Millennials that is the last time we're
gonna say that for probably like two
weeks we haven't decided when we're
coming back I think we're going back
January third Oh early you know the
industry you know isn't opening up till
January seventh I talked about yesterday
and I was like so shook I'm like what
honestly I can't have too much time off
without being on vacation yeah because
then I sleep till two o'clock I'm up
till five o'clock and this show keeps
your girl in line actually the show
really does like give you real structure
to your day and really it is the perfect
time for me to like wake up at like
between 8:30 and 9:00 o'clock is very
reasonable every day well we'll figure
it out but don't don't hold your breath
we'll figure it out um today there will
be a little more toast before the end of
the year because we are still doing
three patreon episodes but this is the
last official free episode of the
morning toast of the year your trial
ends today [ __ ] your free trial for
2018 ends today
you can start again in 2019 and it was
like a year-long trial yeah it was a
trial that's for sure that these for
sure it was very trying today is the
final episode of season one of the
morning toast we will be with season
finale it's the season finale
I can't look we're not having like a
finale party I mean every day is a party
when you're on the morning toast and
Jackie nah it's actually also really not
the last episode because Jackie and I
are doing a live show tonight at
Caroline's in the orchid sold out so
don't try and get tickets I mean it's a
live show it's a holiday extravaganza
it's the morning to us on Broadway
whatever you want to call it um it's
gonna be fabulous it's gonna be fabulous
it's gonna be a good time we truly have
no plans were really just gonna like sit
and hang we're gonna sit and hang but I
think that's what the toasters want for
my say you should hang um it's gonna be
a good time good times are gonna be had
by all if you're looking for a ticket
there's like a couple floating around in
the morning Chaucer's Facebook group and
if you're looking to sell one I would
suggest coming to the morning toasters
Facebook group
okay okay so we're gonna do something
special today because you know whatever
the world turned a little bit but more
importantly it's the last episode of the
morning toast so Jackie and I thought
it'd be fun to do a little recap episode
instead of delivering the Fast Five you
know things that happen in the world
today and yesterday we're gonna deliver
our Fast Five favorite stories of all
time of the year whatever well that is
of all time it's that's what I mean I
believe two favorite stories I did most
sugar
like the biggest stories of the year in
the toast world yeah so in pop culture
and maybe you guys have some other ones
that we forgot about but we're gonna get
into those you're looking very much like
councillor Claude today well thank you
councillor Claude is reporting for doody
camp toast 2019 to you may 17th no 24
yeah sorry I yeah I [ __ ] up the dates
see you May 24th at cam toes I'm Mary
I'm getting really excited for chem
toast cuz we finally decided to make a
camp toast website www.jfn.co.jp/toho a
like going back and forth like bidding
on camp toast commies a bidding war some
old geezer bought the username in the
domain in 2001 and I had to like go back
and forth it was we ended up paying so
much for it but you can't put a price on
chem toast I would love to know what his
plans for camp toast comm work well if
you went to camp toast combat said like
nothing there's nothing here and it was
really annoying because he had
registered in like 2001 so like what do
you think he was doing
I don't know maybe he was thinking of
plans for a morning show with an
accompanying camp I was trying to think
like maybe he meant like cam Potosi you
know like yeah or campo oast camped oast
no camp toe now I don't know however if
you look at the hashtag camp toast it is
inundated with the most beautiful
toasters of all time but but there are a
few outliers of people eating toast bad
camping yeah no I get that because I
follow the hashtag huh so every now and
then I get it pops up with Michael [ __ ]
is this yeah I didn't follow this
whatever I'm making the website now and
I'm not really good at stuff like that
but I'm using Squarespace which is truly
for people like me like no experience I
don't even know what the word
optimization means and it's so easy and
I'm really enjoying it and I just
thought the trust I would like to know
about it in case you have a small
business you're trying to launch and you
need a website you personally do that
sounds very toasty
so if you go to squarespace.com slash
toast for a free trial when you're ready
to launch use the offer code toast to
save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or domain so I got the domain it
was very expensive I didn't get to use
my code because it was a bidding war
you know everyone wanted it but only one
of us prevailed and
so go to squarespace.com forward slash
toast if you're trying to make a website
look I'm truly just like special when it
comes to things like that but
I'm telling you just call me Mark
Zuckerberg these days okay
the website will be up soon Oh like I
said you know I'll hold her breath
because I'm not getting anything done
over the next two weeks
Squarespace we'll have to wait but if
your ticket there is still a handful
left for you and your friends there but
they will probably sell out in January I
would say yeah because I know that
people are waiting the holidays you know
art are tough time yeah um to be
spending frivolous money on the best
camp experience of your life I get that
so I think people are gonna be waiting
for their first paycheck in January so
I'm thinking it's gonna sell out on
January 16th I think there's about 30
tickets left yep yeah about but they're
just flying off the shelves so they
really are it's gonna be so much fun I'm
so excited
me too I feel like we learned a lot
camco squad and we made now it's like I
really feel like we're going back to
camp like see our friends real cameras
living Oh someone said this in the group
they're like we're living t3 we're
living 363 days yesterday I just can't
wait to see just like my chem friends
like Lauren okay me Miranda me Brown was
sending yourself yesterday and she
looked so good and I love her like I
just and I see sometimes very rarely
I'll see camp toasters at my shows I got
mean greets and I always wear their
shirts so like I know but like I would
recognize their face anywhere so when I
was in Buffalo I saw a bunch of the
girls from g4 like who had the best
attitude we thought they were they were
gonna be the mom bunk and they were just
like not and they were so cool
I guess I'm Megan Faygo and Nashville I
did a musical Monday SoulCycle yesterday
don't worry I made it next to a camp
toaster they're everywhere and it was
the cpt or in the back and I will get a
chance say hi Sarah Sobel but I know
you're watching and I saw you in the
mirror and I she was on my show and all
but if she's also a toaster she's a big
I never doubling in size literally and
physically where actually that's well
another patreon episode that I don't
know if I told you that we're gonna do
yet before the end of the year is a fast
five of our years on a personal level
great can't wait to relive the Treach
reload the church but also relive the
chin Oh true that's gonna be a story
hashtag [ __ ] cosmopolitan man of mystery
no house to hashtag why should I
cosmopolitan man of mystery I'm like man
of good energy like good chin ER G
doesn't work okay cuz that sounds like
I'm saying synergy and are you Jack
Donaghy yes so it works so it works well
it is Oh before we Jim I told Jackie I
had a challenge for her cuz I don't know
if you remember earlier in the week you
promised us something and you never
delivered I know what you're gonna say
so oh okay so today while you were
cooing I updated our basket of people
who deserve justice with one Lilly
Moscovitz because you promised you would
deliver justice for her and you didn't
so please Jackie without further ado
here is the the justice servation
also I know it can't be a story but you
know the word justice was named
merriam-webster word of the year yes and
i 100% take credit for that well
together take credit for hundred percent
that is so crazy and no one will ever
admit it no and nobody will understand
but like you and I and Miriam herself
doesn't even know no she got it from but
well over a year ago started saying
justice I know it was April 2017
seventeen were we embarked on a journey
for justice or David Foster and it's
crazy I feel like it's more pertinent to
the situation because we got it we got
justice yesterday and then yesterday
justice was named the word of the earth
and I think you ever wanted proof that
we invented justice your gavel
our gavels well then monogrammed and
everybody need proof if you guys do then
you're at the wrong show also I just
want to say someone who really has us
slip through the cracks
on the Justice Train so I started out
really seeking justice for and I mean
we've clearly chosen our sides but still
justice for Chris Humphries like oh yeah
I got a raw deal he gets to go in here I
think I had his face printed out
somewhere I'll update it for for season
two but it's like I'm totally team came
I really am but like Kris Humphries got
a raw deal totally okay Lilly Moscovitz
so here's the thing as a as a history
meter I really like to do my research
before I give a pollution and origin
right or before I really hone in on my
thesis and I haven't rewatched a movie
since I said I would serve up justice
for her so I'm going off of memory
memories eight years of emotions and
like rethinking through the way I see
the movie now here we have Lilly
Moscovitz a girl with a big smile with
two chins many a butter pie clip now
this is just a girl I remember the
feeling this is just a girl who wants to
have a good time of course wants to
share in memories with her best friend a
girl who up until her grandma came to
town was an embarrassment and also a
girl who just wanted to make premium
content and a girl who at the end of the
day started boning her brother totally
and you know what like that's kind of
gross totally now here she is an
entrepreneur out here starting her own
web show you know really and this was in
the 90s like really before the
technology became so democratized and
brought to the people and Lilly really
was the first person to take that step
in and you know give herself a voice use
this platform to give her high school
self this voice and so she was at this
prep school with her embarrassing
looking for anything you know really
could have made it on her own
no totally like she would Styles if
you're worried Gran Hathaway like
brighten her town with that haircut with
that haircut with with the cats like
just no bueno no boy but Lilly wasn't
gonna give up on her cause she's a good
friend she's a good friend so my mentor
does she have to carry around this dead
weight for years then one day the dead
weight turns into a butterfly right I'm
lucky and she's still like can't hack it
and Lilly has to once again embarrass
herself in front of the whole class fall
on her sword Bulls hair hair okay I
posted that ceiling on Instagram I think
Instagram is on to us specifically
because currently what you have to do do
you want to know is you have to alter
the volume they're not on to us it's
just like they process it's like YouTube
how even when you played [ __ ] Celine
Dion songs son's song on soundcloud yeah
they knew that it was copyrighted you
have to change the volley and pitch or
somebody but can I tell you something
how they're onto us
because yesterday on the chess Instagram
I posted a clip of Miley on SNL like
with her tits almost coming out and I
directly downloaded rip to the video
from a my leaf an account that literally
same exact video and there's the still
up and mine was gone in 10 seconds maybe
was because we have a hundred thousand
followers what a day for 100,000
couldn't picked a better day totally
thanks justice day things always along
for us the justice the hundred thousand
the season finale on my 21st birthday I
woke up went to the Taylor Swift concert
and reached a million followers even
though I wasn't on schedule to reach a
million followers for like another two
days just like by the algorithm right
God like jumped me to the front of the
line and he took those followers back
don't worry like a couple days later
like I literally dropped it was crazy
but it was God literally the universe
just has a way of aligning things for
you and that's exactly what happened
that's exactly what happened except for
Lilly Moscovitz he was wrong and a
mistake now she's on a justice stick so
things are gonna turn around her you
know I had I had the full confidence
that's a good feeling about William I'm
like don't and then she was supposed to
have the interview of the lifetime
getting on the princess and like finally
all of her years of hard work of being a
friend are gonna pay off right that
would be like if you know like Margot
Lewin just like married Prince Harry
Megan Markel was left for daddy like and
then it was ours
what's her market burger and like that's
our friend and the she didn't do the
interview with us like that's what it
would be like she stood us out oh but
you get your toaster she wouldn't know
she would have been and would have
thought that Lilly was a true friend
Mike or vice-versa
what's her real name in the movie Mia
Thermopolis oh yeah and I had one Oh
when she's ready to the street screaming
after her friend wait up and they see
what's turn around not you iconic truly
truly iconic Oh anyways I got your gavel
Jackie because this justice has been
served
where's my gavel that's what I want to
know I don't know I don't have a table
like you do no but you have your baskets
you know I just I wonder where my gavel
is we gotta find it cuz that's a piece
of history and it's proof that we
invented the phrase racist you know and
it couldn't have gone too far to be
right the dayton there but it says the
morning breath but you know we'll just
scratch it out
um well Thank You Jackie for that
wonderful presentation and now without
further ado it's time we dive into the
fast five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast the last time so
it's not really the stories that you
need to know this morning it's the
stories that you needed to know this
year so if this is your first ever time
watching the morning toast you're
actually in luck because we're gonna
break down the entire year from Munich
for you in chronological order okay
now the biggest story of the year which
actually feels really good that
doing this episode because we did not
get a chance to talk about it oh I think
we did actually because tell me I'll
tell you
swarmy Webster she took the world by
storm II she truly did she was born on
Super Bowl weekend so we definitely
talked about at the following day ya
said justice first where me come he
never got to talk about it but we also
did a live show a live stream from that
party so no but like - I remember on
Super Bowl Sunday Kiley released that
video yeah so we definitely talked about
it the next day totally anyways that was
so crazy I mean the fact that she kept
that entire pregnancy secret even though
the world knew but like we didn't really
know what a part of me was like this is
just some [ __ ] enews started rumor
but then I was like no wait it's not
because she released a video she kept
this pregnancy like the people around
her like the fact that there was
probably like 30 people who knew and
really nobody like gave the secret away
or gave out definitive proof that had
happened or released a picture it's just
a testament to like Kylie being so
obsessed with her like from the past
three seasons of Keeping Up with the
Kardashians when Kylie really started to
grow up all she wanted to do was hang
out with her friends like Sheen even she
cares more about her friends and she
does her family and now I know why she's
less friends yeah that's what Kim said
it in in the little documentary was like
keep my friends close you have such
great friends and no one spilled the
secret do you know how much money they
could have gotten like a million so she
has good friends and rich friends right
because she takes because she they all
live in our house right and they don't
pay bills and they don't need the money
yeah
did you see that video of Jordan it's
like one minute straight up I Legion I
send it to you oh did you it was so fun
it was so funny okay do you think
there's any day are there what's even
crazier about the story Webster story is
that the world revolves around the toast
because we knew the name yeah the
t-shirts made the name when there was
speculation that she was pregnant even
though we weren't even sure if she was
pregnant
someone in the toaster found out the
name because they worked out some baby
store that was making a custom crib with
the name on it and told us we know
everything it's crazy and what's so
crazy is like there's a couple things
where the biggest name of the year this
year it was stormy mm-hmm like storm use
such a random name get two of the most
prevalent characters of the year are
named stormy whose other ones from
Daniels you know it's so funny I was
literally just having this conversation
with someone
oh no zero on the toast yesterday I
don't know anything that goes on in the
world's like with the politics and
Oh who's that she's a stripper s yeah
pornstar both whatever I think now she
just got a job stripping like and
actually that we make I was listening I
was talking to someone they said she did
the most amazing interview on Bill Maher
like they said she was a class act but
I'm like she's a stripper I don't know
no you could be both yeah
cardi B watches carpool karaoke no was
she on it yes yesterday it came out like
last night this morning you know hard to
keep up because like no one watches it
for real they just really said on
YouTube she is like so cute and by the
way she's so skinny
I didn't notice but she was like the
tightest shirt and sitting in a car like
this roll city not our own site do you
see what she said she's like been losing
so much weight since she gave birth she
actually doesn't want to be anyway yeah
because you bet when you breastfeed you
go you lose a lotta weight
yeah interesting well I'll have to try
that when I feed my breasts to someone
other than Ben or CEO Oh cute man I
thought maybe he would bring him today
well you know I was going to but my dog
walker is like always thirty minutes
late so it's like you start to come at
8:30 and I leave at 9:45 so it's an 8:30
9:30 on a field will be ready to go he
didn't come till 9:00 so I wasn't gonna
wait and be late you know yeah yeah I
love my dog walker but he's always late
but he doesn't seal for me so like
potato potato truly um anyways really
just so crazy like a year ago we didn't
know if Kiley like a year ago today we
didn't know what kind of his pregnant
look at you know she is the mom of a
generation a year ago Kiley was just a
kid now she's a mom to a child and a
billion-dollar brand and honestly I
wouldn't only hope for that kind of glow
up in one year I hope next year I have a
child and a billion-dollar brand right
now I have a million dollar brand sort
of and next year I want a billion dollar
brand that's have you got to go on Shark
Tank yeah we really do I think about it
every day and I think I can't help but
think that like Shark Tank knows about
us I think I'm like self-centered and I
think that like literally everyone in
the world knows about us cuz like they
do
we're like some intern there right
that's always what it is it's like okay
maybe market Cuban doesn't know who we
are before humans you know wives
personal assistants sister watches the
toast and that's good enough for me
totally
next story of the biggest stories of the
year that shook us who didn't stop
talking about Chloe and Tristan you know
what I was excited about this episode
then I realized we have to relive all
the treacherous Nell ignoring I know
okay what happened tell me recap it what
happened Chloe moved to Cleveland to be
with her man Tristan everyone thought
like this was it for her this was it for
her once she loved she finally got
pregnant it means you think that she
wasn't getting pregnant with Lamar all
those years because God was looking out
for her this was a man that she was
supposed to be Wed three days before her
labor due to news drops Tristan was like
out and about with some club thoughts
and no didn't turn out the video was
from October no then more videos were
including one from October Kris Jenner
was just like Harvey release them all
but I read somewhere that it wasn't a
Kris Jenner thing it was like the club
owner of that club was going through
like tough times and then and didn't I
gave up the video but then when
everything was coming out sold the video
so she could like pay for her club seems
a little convenient but I'll take it
I'll take it yeah and I mean and it's
just a funny because this happened six
months ago but we've been reliving it on
Keeping Up with the Kardashians so this
recently this little saga has truly
taken up the entire year between when it
actually happened and they're reliving
of it all right and then the aftermath
of course so honestly like I don't care
anymore no I look I love Chloe I wish
her good things you made your bed now
lie in it and if cliff tristin's x2 you
will see you know and I mean it really
as much as it was also unfortunate it
created great content for their show and
for our show is the first week of our
show you know we were feeling a little
nervous of course we didn't know when
this like just this this bomb dropped
down our laps and who else is gonna
break it down for you unlike the morning
toast I mean nobody that's the thing and
you know what I had a thought now that
you said that I've been trying to find a
place to like interject my thought into
the show because I was like I thought of
it last night and you know what I think
we need to do and it's annoying because
like in order to do it we need like
actually 1 billion dollars but if we had
1 billion dollars and people are was
like 40 want to do with the toast like
what's your career dream like blah blah
yes you know big Netflix special all
that but I really feel like and I can't
believe that there isn't a 24 hours a
new news network about pop culture like
CNN Fox for pop culture and I was
explaining it to Ben last night and he
was like but so much happens in politics
you wouldn't have enough to talk about
I'm like that's so not sure I would say
just as much happens in politics that
happens in pop culture and people don't
realize but the real news like the CNN
and five like
is recycled they say the same [ __ ] 100
times like they have to pull [ __ ] out of
their ass all the time it's like so sad
to watch sometimes so like and then I
was thinking I'm like I think that's
what II was intended to be like a
24-hour news network but like or just
like what a 24-hour like millennial
hotspot but like it's not because
they're not in tune with what's
necessary and I really feel like if we
could get 24 hours of non-stop content
like that would be sick and it would be
like okay so seven seven days a week we
need 24 hours of content break you down
24 hours every episode would play twice
because like people missed it so that's
12 hours of content the toast that's 11
I would have to give Heather McManus
show 10 we have 10 other shows we could
think of 10 other like influencer
celebrities that we want to give
pop-culture shows to to break it down
for us right I think like I don't know
how we even start to do it but that
would be so epic a 24 hour pop culture
news network called toast TN n toast
news network
done I'm here for it I'll do a double
shift me too
I'm nowhere to be me neither I knew it -
come home - yeah no but you need to be
like a Murdoch or something - right like
that seems like the the money but like
the resources we would need but like I
just want to put it out there there
needs to be a 24-hour pop culture news
network and I'm like oh I want to turn
on the news but like more so on engines
know what cardi B's commenting on
Instagram right and it's like and I
always seemed like who would play it
okay oh here's a perfect example our
friend Margo who's a toaster like works
in an office with a bunch of other
toasters it's like a lot of young girls
let's say they have a TV in there like
what are they gonna play 24 hours like
they're probably gonna put on Bravo but
it's like you need to be watching Bravo
now this is something that's on in the
background of every cool millennial nail
salon office that's just like keeping
you informed totally and then and most
offices do watch hello office people
watch the toast up on their TV like as
an office right but it's only one hour a
day and they're there for like eight
more hours right very sad I know okay
like goals goals it's good to have goals
yeah and now that's 20 and it's the last
show like we should be setting
resolutions goals for ourselves that's
out of 2019 because that's a little
unrealistic that's like a 2025 goal for
ya
do you want to know what one of my
career goes that goals is it's not like
reaching for the stars but it's like
reaching for them I don't know like the
spaceship on the way to the stars
but I want to be on Dancing with the
Stars one day oh okay that's attainable
attainable but like you have to be a big
enough star or a big enough digital star
right like hayes grier wasn't it we're
big enough digital star like just famous
enough to be onions with you would be
good at it cuz you're a good day and I
think I would win the Mirrorball trophy
yeah even though it's not even about
some no but it's about both it's about
popularity and talent right because they
you don't have to get to the popular
stage if you're talented enough right
got it
but and then if you're popular enough
you don't have to be that talented right
until the end
okay so that would be me like popular
but not talented right so I think if I
could and I can I think I would you want
to dance with Gleb I don't know any of
them so I don't know someone who's super
patient and then you lose so much weight
yeah and it's and then you're this on TV
once a week a dream right and sometimes
twice a week in the Q costumes exactly
but I've heard it's really stressful no
it's very difficult on your body number
one Barbara Corcoran came on the show
and she was like I got on the plane I
just started hysterically crying she's
like I don't remember but it sounds
Larry
she was like I've never lost anything
before my life she was so upset she was
funny she was so fat [ __ ] back on the
show third story taking the world by
storm II Webster this year the Royal
Wedding which happens what a day and you
know the world one it was tough cuz it
was not a Sunday so we weren't actually
alive and the timing like I woke up and
so much had already happened and like
that was annoying yeah it was really
hard to keep up um but it was just a
very cool day for the world to come
together on something that's just really
so beautiful but I love stuff like that
like just things that the world watches
together right I imagine that's how
people feel about the World Cup I don't
watch you the Olympics like e.coli yeah
lettuce yeah not like not anything
something that's not political if you
can't be divisive about just something
that we all come to watch and like
comment on yeah well that would bring me
to the next story
um but are we done with Megan mark oh
yeah I mean if someone would say what
was 2018 the year of I would say 2018
was a year Megan Markel 100% she was the
only alive person who was in the top 10
most searched on Google I think you also
could have said the year before the year
before they got engaged so it was like
the lead-up but then next year's gonna
be about Megan to because she's gonna
give birth right but that nothing
there's nothing it's never gonna be as
big of a deal as it was in 2018 because
like like she was like the rumor about
Kylie being pregnant like I heard about
her and
Prince Harry like being linked I'm like
oh that's just like another rumor that
you know someone started and they made
it like when I'm indeed right and then
all of a sudden they're like in the
garden saying they're engage and I was
like what the [ __ ]
actually I was like what the [ __ ] no
that was so crazy like I think when that
moment happened I remember us doing the
show like and watching that little
livestream they did I think I was more
shocked at that and that I was that
Kylie was pregnant yeah cuz they were
both rumors that I was like are probably
not true but the Megan one was just like
two unbelievable to be believable you
know and I wasn't super other than barks
fly no I've never watched me neither so
I knew she was on Deal or No Deal I know
she was a hallmark girl and then I'd
heard about suits but like if you don't
watch suits I'm sorry it's just a random
show on USA like no offense I even if
you watch suits it's just a random [ __ ]
on us like apparently it's one of the
better ones one of the better ones on
USA what is that saying the only
competition is Chris Lee no or okay
comparatively I watch this show Queen of
the South it's a random show on USA like
it's one of those characters who was
married pretty like that'd be so crazy
so it's so crazy and that was also
before I watched the crown so I didn't
really understand that the importance of
like her being engaged to him like
having been eating just divorced like
that that was so crazy and really just
showed how prick how much progress has
been made then I watch the crown and now
I feel like I know everything yeah and
you do yeah no that was what a year for
Megan Markel I wonder if she's looking
back on her year while yelling at some
maid just being like this is a good year
for me yeah for sure but I think she has
bigger plans for next year honestly no
totally it's like for her it's like
alright phase one complete next up world
domination and I say she could do it
though if anyone can if anyone can now
she's unlimited resources the taxpayer
dollars are at her beck and call
she's a million maids who just keeps
leaving the country and she could do it
yeah okay
and then another story that I don't know
if it qualifies as the top five story of
the year but to me it did and it's a
similar thing where it's like the whole
world was just captivated by it and in a
totally light ron's trance if we were in
in a trance which was the tie cave
rescue
and that was like sad too it was like it
was sad while it was happening but I
feel like being on this side of the
world we were only hearing the news like
1215 hours after it was happening so we
were only hearing good news I know yes
two seals died Oh
one seal one done like that was turb
that was terrible and I'm glad the kids
got out but like what the hell was he
doing in there but like kids like boys
like what they would get out and we
would hear like we didn't have to go
through there like yeah every minute
right
so for us over here I mean aside from
like the fall from grace for Elon Musk's
right no but then like the added layer
was that you on musk of it are getting
himself involved offering to make some
engineered thing that they claim was
literally like not like I don't know who
to believe because I was just watching
me on Twitter he went to this high
school he practiced in the pool he built
this thing that was big enough for the
kids it could turn in the quarters and
was engineered properly and he sent it
over and the apparently the people in
Thailand were like this is never gonna
work and this is plastic like go [ __ ]
yourself that's what the guy who we got
in a fight with says burn burn Unsworth
said who we call the pedophile so I mean
just like the added element of the drama
on top of the drama was just exciting
for me it was really crazy and people
were so invested in and we were because
like we were on a TNN but like I I went
to Amy so this was in June I went to Amy
Schumer it's show I guess a month later
and she was talking about it
funniest thing she was talking about the
tie heat Bresee I remember what her joke
was but she was like is it weird that I
kind of miss it like she was like it was
so like the camaraderie yeah and I
remember Dana was like so invested in it
people a really like it was just one of
those things I just by the way and this
is so unbelievable to say like I love
those things not that someone died
obviously just like moments where the
world comes together to watch something
and when there's a happy ending like all
the kids got out like that is just great
do you want to know what's so crazy that
I learned about that because I went on a
trip with my friends my mom went to
Atlantic City and all of my friends were
really like captivated by the story more
so than I ever thought it might look
smart friend like yeah my friends they
literally like share books like they're
always losers they're like always
reading books but I'd never see them
reading which is the best kind of reader
and oh it's like annoying when they're
like oh sorry I can't talk right like
they all have like Kindle so I
assume they're on their iPads like
everything like I'm Instagram but
they're really like reading Tina's like
probably the most well-read person I
know and you also know that she has a
photographic memory yes I did know that
so she's just like a baby genius anyways
they were talking about the cave rescue
mission and they were saying what's so
crazy is that when they were rescuing
the kids they had to take the strongest
ones out first you would think they'd
take the weakest ones because like they
can't make it but technically like they
take the strongest ones cuz they have
the best chance of survival so literally
the last kid who got rescued was like
the weakest skinniest but then that's
like the scariest part being there alone
like so they got the kid there's two
left
they take the second kid you're waiting
for them to come back I think there was
someone that maybe the coach was so with
them are something like I don't think
there was ever like one kid alone there
but the kid who's the weakest and and
closest to passing right has to go last
that's so sad it's like survival of the
fittest and also question how did they
get in there they were they were on a
tour of the caves like walking through
when they went like I guess a few miles
in and then there was a flood shook so
they had to go see how they had to keep
going in to see high ground right and
when they were making it harder for
themselves to get out yes so crazy so
sad but like I can't wait for the movie
yeah who was gonna play the coach who's
gonna play Elon Musk himself he's the
only man who could do it including
myself okay then the next story I was
gonna say Ariana and Pete but I'm gonna
open it up to all of the engagements
broken engagements and we have one
marriage of in here right and say what
you want but like they seem tight like
Halley and Justin seemed too strong I'm
sorry two marriages Nick and Priyanka oh
right yeah no I was talking about like
underage kids getting married like and
okay of the three engagements that
happened this year which was pean Ariana
and Nick and Priyanka and Halley and
Justin if you would ask me in the
beginning of the year one of these
couples gets married who would it be one
of these couples breaks up who would it
be hmm
Peter Rihanna obviously really they were
just too hot and too heavy I might have
said Halley and Justin because like
their track records aren't the worst his
track record but them as a couple are
pretty consistent they were together
once for
long time and he was still public about
how much he loved her and then he went
through some stuff and whatever so and I
don't know they seemed to be united by
God and what's stronger than God you
know right nothing remember when I
literally said that that on the show
then you were right and that I was right
I mean there's definitely like other
stuff going dry but I really and what's
so crazy is like I've really like come
to question and T these days cuz I'm
like you know some of the stuff he says
it's too outrageous and I just can't
believe it but when he came on our
podcast at the height of Pete and Ariana
being so in love running around bleached
hair you know fanny pack high boots
paparazzi living in Chelsea Bonaparte
man all that stuff I said now whatever
he said and I thought it was the
craziest thing he said if Ariana lease
Pete he will try to kill himself in the
next six months I don't like your
[ __ ] nuts and who are you to speak on
that mental health of others well here
we are here we are I just hope that he
doesn't do it that like I really am
still like I loved them I didn't even
know how much I loved them until they
broke up really I'm like you want to
know why I'm like not happy they broke
up but just like I'm over it is because
it's like the Chrissy Teigen effect like
the e-news of it all right you know like
they couldn't be left alone someone
commented they posted something
obviously yesterday about Pete and
Ariana and someone left a comment was
like you guys literally post about the
same like four or five people and they
responded they like think they're so
funny they're like oh come on it's more
like six or seven it's so annoying
there's someone going and they made Pete
Ariana annoying
yeah and the beginning they were sweet
and like when it was just their
instagrams like I was slipping for it I
remember what they mean you can follow a
news like maybe that's what it is right
because I've known following all the
people that they talk about cuz I only
want to see it once right maybe maybe
news but sometimes like they might have
the story for like yeah if I don't see
it there I'm not gonna see it and
sometimes I think they just post stuff
to be controversial like they posted
literally so randomly a picture of
Kirsten Kristen Bell and duck Shepard
yesterday and when you see that you're
like oh divorce but they were like
silver bells Kristen Bell I can't write
like thirst I remember the first time we
talked about Pete and Ariana we like
there was a page six story that they
like had hooked up at a party and I was
like there's literally no way that this
is true like or that they were like
seeing each other and I was like
maybe maybe they hooked about a party
once but like this is not a relationship
like no and I Wow I was wrong
you were wrong where's Ariana right now
like cuz I was thinking she apparently
are yes geographically because it was so
weird that she like lived in New York
cuz I feel like she's so LA so but when
she was Pete they were full-time living
in in New York but I think she lives in
LA now really like she's too big of a
star not type of big house you know I
don't know but she is kind of East Coast
so not gonna live in Boca then New York
might be the place to her I'm really all
here for somebody's living in New York
he's no chance of seeing them and I'm
getting in the background I'm a
paparazzi but I always get the vibe that
if a celebrity lives in New York they're
a little bit more down-to-earth you know
and like one more like a normal life
yeah but New York the hustle and bustle
the hustle and bustle I love your boots
today thank you
well you know I'm really only starting
to like I was actually saying this about
the other day and he thought it was
being like such a diva I said to him I'm
like I'm at this point in my life where
like I think I am successful enough to
not have to wear heels like I would sure
like I said like not like an event like
where Manny photographed yeah I'm
talking about just like going out with
my friends like I think you know what I
don't want to wear [ __ ] heels I don't
think that you have to you know and I
just feel like I'm like internet famous
now like I don't want to and like it's
for some reason I feel justified in
doing so and not having to like show up
to the proper dress code because I'm
like I have a modicum of fame
well it's crazy because when I don't
wear heels like I feel like the shortest
girl on the road like yesterday with the
foster sisters with the saucer it was
like elf sister yeah I mean they were so
telling me we're so small and small but
then I wear heels and I'm like wow I'm a
big galoot like I'm I feel so tall when
I wear heels and it's like nothing I'm
like I feel like I look ridiculous well
anyway like I'd rather feel short I'm
Jamie has really changed a game for me
because they're a quality Italian luxury
shoes but like made they're made this is
what they say made the old way sold the
new way so they're not that expensive
they're the same quality is like Gucci
really like fine Italian other brands
but they're not that expensive so I
don't feel it's been spending money on
shoes that I maybe you know you know
won't wear like I buy shoes now for my
closet because I have this gorgeous
closet and this gorgeous shoe to slice
so I'm
Adam Jamie adding to cart adding to cart
and each cart you know just because I
want to see them in my closet like I
bought I bought pair shoes yesterday
that from em Jamie and I say a picture
and you were like I love that I'm like
great I don't know if I'll wear them but
they're in my closet now just for the
Instagram you know like cardi B said
she's five cars she doesn't know how to
drive why so she could take pictures
with them totally that's why I feel
about shoots down I feel like about em
Jamie it's like I wear them the most out
of all my jacket he really does MJ me as
an Italian luxury made made the old way
sold the new way merging time-honored
Italian shoe making with a modern custom
experience so basically there's no
substitute for Italian luxury shoe wear
Footwear okay so go see for yourself how
amazing these shoes are at I'm Jimmy
dot-com slash toast for $50 off your
first pair damn that's a lot of money
off that's letters M GE m Icom slash
toast like the bread for $50 off your
first pair M Jimmy calm slash toast em
Jimmy Italian luxury made the old way
sold the new way literally my favorite
shoes and one of my favorite slogans
oh the old way so the new way got him so
purchased well check them out I'm Jimmy
comma slash toast and that was our fifth
story correct yes that's it so with the
year that's what you missed this year
that's what you missed on Glee
by the way that was like a busy year
everyone always is us but others is also
an honorable mention story would be Demi
Lovato perhaps oh yes that was actually
crazy also all the deaths of the year
but there's deaths every year yeah and
you know celebrities they don't threes
this year it was like 12 was it I mean
it's a package add this year Anthony
Bourdain hates paid Stanley yes okay
whatever well I posted Ike the Franklin
oh yeah I got um I had an idea just cuz
like whatever we delivered the past five
but I wanted to make today's special so
I decided to get some questions some
gear and questions from the toasters
from the morning toasters face of a
group if I'm not a part of feel free to
apply if you're still waiting to get in
please ever ask me when you're gonna get
in because we don't have the bed
the fastest way for you to get in is
really to join the patient and the toast
after New York and then I'll let you
into the morning toasters group but the
groups have been on a free since toast
me get in but you'll all get in soon but
today was I mean this year was a crazy
year we launched the toast so much
personal and professional growth that I
thought you know why not why not insert
a couple questions really haven't had an
opportunity to like look back on there
yet so I'm excited to get into this
headspace and some future predictions
about the toast so first question from
obviously number one toaster Liz height
who are some guests you really want to
nail in 2019 and I mean for the show not
sexually okay I guess I could answer
both um still my dream guests I said
this um a year ago one of my dream
guests is Kelly Clarkson because I love
her as a talent and I also think like
she would get on so famously with I
think so too like it would be a great
show um then obviously they're the usual
suspects Kim Chi you know dream guest
right I think for me john mayer's is a
guest and I think I've said that before
and I think in 2019 I do think that we
could get Kim on the show and let me
tell you why she's done two podcast so
far second of all like people like of an
older generation love to just be like Oh
Millennials like this like let me do it
you know and like we are truly the
Millennial morning show and I think Kim
is smart and she's a smart businesswoman
and I think there's a chance and I feel
like I now have like six one degree of
separation relationships with Kim and
just one of them has to pan out mm-hmm I
also some other celebrity deaths of
people are money Mac Miller avicii John
McCain oh you know who's the guest that
I would love to have him very attainable
Meghan McCain oh but I was gonna say
Morgan Stewart oh yes
yes she just doesn't live in New York
right that's a Sima Stasi they're both
like we can get them and we will but
they just we just have to go to LA and
record like six episodes
who was your favorite guest in 2018 I'll
have an oven make a wish TN and TN n TN
and TN and TN n TN and TN aunty Anna
who's your favorite guest is here oh wow
that's so hard I really want to say this
is source buster no I know but it's like
so easy to say because we just had that
I felt like so invigorated after
yesterday's episode and like
accomplished and I felt like just good
I'm gonna say the foster sisters but I'm
also going to say because not only is
she an incredible guest co-host and
person but
this was like the year that we were
introduced to heather mccanna and things
will never be the same no truly this is
from Jordan bit tick what has been the
most surreal / pinch me moment of the
toast in 2018 Wow okay I would say one
number one podcast in Massachusetts in
New Jersey that was crazy and that was
only like one or two months into yeah
that was in May that was Wow
it was a month and half right one of the
toasters worked on the team that
publishes no she worked for the research
company so can you guys do another one
soon because they want to know if we've
grown at all I wanted I mean we have
grown numbers well but like if we have
conquered another state I would say
pinch me moment was two things one was
Kacey Musgraves just like knowing our
presence that was [ __ ] crazy at the
CMAs and two was iTunes naming us not
even naming us just did their analytic
research and we are one of like the top
10 most downloaded new shows of 2018 we
were there with goop like that was cool
and Dax Shepard yeah everyone was like
unestablished 70 they were really none
that were even what I would call like
our competitor no and iTunes is always
doing annoying ass like promotion
editors picks and like we don't work
with iTunes at all so like any time
we've ever like our numbers if we're on
the charts like it's just from toaster
boots-on-the-ground like we did with
battle cloud yeah so that was cool
because we don't work with Apple at all
they did their editors picks our
favorite shows basically shows that they
fighting for harmony what's new and note
where is right but they shoes I'm too
valuable
this was undeniable and so that was
numbers don't lie that was don't lie and
also I would say we'll see ma words and
working with Access Hollywood just
getting that sort of like no that was a
bit um recognition from VMAs and Access
Hollywood respecting the hell out of the
morning toast and also like the respect
that Olivia capo had for us on the show
yeah well we'll never forget this is
from Alison W because let's just leave
it at that
where you going on vacation for
Christmas Dominican Republic I'm not
going anywhere I'm going to Miami
tomorrow to work I have two shows one of
them sold out other one is like 30
tickets left tickets available girls no
job com I'll see you at the Miami improv
it's gonna be late I have some very
special guests in attendance at some of
the shows oh and I also want to say a
surreal moment was camp toast oh yeah
holding it off and then being there and
like there were so many times where all
the girls everything just either turned
into karaoke put dance party
or a therapy session yeah and really the
therapy sessions like just hearing like
what the toast like has meant to people
even in my DMS but just meeting people
like and knowing how they got here like
what brought you to the Poconos to meet
some internet friends oh yeah was really
it makes it all worth doing no totally
and like anytime I get it I go to a
meeting reading someone writes me a
letter it's always about how the toast
like means so much to them and like I
get it but I don't get to experience the
toast as just a toaster like I'm a
toaster obviously but almost a purveyor
of the toast so I don't get to
experience the toast in everyday life
like other people do and I don't really
ever get to fully understand like how
meaningful it is to people until I get
to meet them and then have them tell me
and that's epic and that's that is the
best part like I'm just doing what I do
and even a co-leader most basic level
like the people who enjoy the toasts
most are people who like just work
boring jobs and you actually never had
to do that but as someone who has worked
in boring ask her in America like I
would have I would have been the biggest
toaster of all time is there this is
such a good question from Caitlin Arnold
is there any celebrity that you used to
hate or had in the Umbridge basket on
the show that changed your minds in 2018
there were a lot that came to light for
me yes um I would say one randomly is
Shakira I just like used to always think
negative things about her because there
was like once this rumor that she said
something mean about Jews um and just
after everything that we went through
and it's like you can't like one there
was there was no like quote or anything
and she's never like right I just I let
that one go it was such a good one you
know like I feel really mean change how
I felt about people just like based on
what other people said about them yeah I
think we used to have this overall
mentality of like where there's smoke
there's fire
and it's like there there's a weird
rumor about you Kat Von D that you're
anti-semitic like there you probably are
but having been through the ringer of
and the other side like opinion where
people are like you're so judgmental and
racist and like come over to my house
I'm not like I'm cool I could chill I
love you I don't care that like I now
had a whole new respect for anyone who's
ever been labeled as something because
it's so people just like you get the
label once and you're automatically it
and it never it never goes away and that
[ __ ] sucks and having to deal with
that is terrible so now having been
someone who like pervaiz those labels
and then also went through I'm like no
I'm not doing that [ __ ] anymore
also so let me meet you first
one L see my opinion on has change we
had like a short talk about this a few
weeks ago is Chrissy Teigen mm-hmm
because I think that it's really like
the buzz seats in the unions is up the
world that make her like annoying wench
I think she really is just like a cool
girl who's a fan of these shows and like
likes to cook them and as a professional
fan and he's obsessed with her husband
and Bravo yeah which like it comes off
as annoying when you read it in a
BuzzFeed recap written by an annoying
person who lives in Brooklyn but if I
ever like do go on her Twitter and read
it firsthand for myself from the primary
source and like damn this [ __ ] is so
funny and she's not doing it for
anything other than her own enjoyment
hmm she doesn't need the money
no for lip sync battle this is our
Abigail Clarke and we got this question
like a million times is there any hope
of fan Friday coming back yes
yeah we just got to figure out the
safety of it because now that we don't
have the protection of like a verizon
security desk and it's just like hey
come on in I just need to know who we're
inviting in no and it's like just the
logistical setup and what not it's it's
just like a lot of moving pieces and
we're the only two like right because
I'm intern but like it's just a lot to
manage but we would love to do that this
is a good question from Melissa case
what our mains is and one jiz favorite
thing that happened to you both in 2018
like what does that most proud of oh I'm
sure it's us getting engaged know
professionally chose yeah obviously it's
you getting engaged um there are some
things that we do that like he thinks is
so cool that like to me it's just like
another day totally and I have to think
honestly even though it's not well it
was this year but it wasn't a part of
the toast was a Super Bowl oh yeah but
whatever we still did it [ __ ] that I can
take responsibility I mean I take credit
for that for sure I think for Ben it's
and also for me too was my show was in
Boston cuz like that was really cool and
then hadn't been to a show and so long
because I started I used to only do
shows on the weekend so like Ben and
everyone could come and fly but now it's
like a real thing so I do it on the
weekday so Ben hasn't been able to come
but he got to come to the shows in
Boston cuz they were on the weekend and
I think that he he like he knows the
power of the Cho's just from like people
coming up to him and be like I'm gonna
love the toast but I think him getting
to see it firsthand because he's never
been to like a toast live show her a
moment where like the toast is so crazy
so that was like a culmination of just
everything and I think that was like for
him like wow yeah someone reminded me
Thomas I think mames is really liked and
proud and impressed with our merch
what's it look like what we made and
like the coolness quality Aryan - like
branding and then like selling out in
the way that we did and like all he
wanted in his life was a black pop
socket she really made that up no of
course not but we have extras here and
then he got his own pop socket like
amazing else no just something else and
he like hates how you bring him he hates
the pop socket life why I don't know he
liked it didn't I don't have one since I
got a new phone case meaning my life but
we have yeah boolean I need one yeah oh
we should have given out to the I
usually try and give it to the guest but
I forget um sorry I should have there's
gonna be dead air give me a second
that's okay do you want me to sing sure
there's always gonna be another mountain
this is a good question from Liz hi
Jackie
what are some of your professional and
personal goals of 2019 not related to
the chose okay great question thanks um
Dancing with the Stars comes back in
spring of 2020 right so like I don't
know remember that was a new story but
they're going on break there's no Sun
we're on break so like maybe that is
hang they get back and then also
expanding my hosting range you know I
would love don't a couple auditions on a
collection I went on one audition last I
just came up in your time home and it
just came up in my time hopping it's
like the most embarrassing it was a
horrible experience it was for the
history digital channel like history.com
digital which would have been perfectly
she would have been part of so well read
and like it was just not good
no yeah but you need to be like you know
you need oh my god cuz been made last
night made me do this stupid app breathe
like where people read to you or
whatever you need to do that could you
of such like a professional voice I feel
like I have an annoying voice but it's
like you only even in a way for us when
you hang out with me which is all the
time but perhaps and if I'm reading off
a tolerance anyways to get more into the
hosting ral me in a more legitimate
capacity and when are you gonna do your
lipstick because I've been on your ass
about it no I okay and I found it
literally distributor do you know how
hard it is do it no no it's not just
that like there are so many logistics
but that is a goal of mine that I've
been working on so to Corinne I know she
has like a legit thing going
you should do it um Jackie it's your
last unmarried year what do you think
will change once you tie that on not
like too much but I think I'll just like
really I really want to learn how to
cook this year and like I really want to
become like more of a domestic not like
too much but learning how to cook really
thinking about like when I want to start
a family totally
you know like that'll be that's tough
cuz like I'm so we're so focused
career-wise but then like having kids is
so important but also it like stops the
career you know first a little this is
like so terrible but like if I'm
pregnant I can't go Dancing with the
Stars
hey totally that's something to either
have to like get ready really soon and
give birth and then go on or like hold
out this is our moment
Miranda Mae brown where do you see the
toast being this time next year ooh
well I was saying cuz I was reading
these questions I thought I saw this
morning I'm like if the toast is exactly
where it is next year like I won't be
nad no if they toast it if we're sitting
right here next year with like double
the numbers which like you know our
growth is exponential and it's all about
like really patience people think like
oh how are you gonna grow in the next
month like well yeah you laced one web
show your own viral how much are you
gonna put behind Facebook as like stupid
we don't spend any money on marketing
like our marketing strategy is good
content and patience and it will bear
fruit so if we're sitting here in a year
from now with three times as many people
watching like that would be good enough
for me yeah yeah maybe just an elevated
set yeah a revamp toast 2.0 I'm here
always here for what is your favorite
toaster meetup moment like a moment this
year where you ran into a toaster they
said something that made you feel good
whatever oh well my favorite toaster
toaster meetup this year was when we
went out after our Nashville show oh man
I went alleged it was and we went it so
hard so hard I literally couldn't walk
we slept till 4:00 o'clock the next day
did we
you have been called the hotel I know
people were sending us room service and
they couldn't get in our room cuz really
dead to the world yeah oh my god no
literally been called the hotel and
that's how we woke up literally the
hotel room phone started ringing and
we're like what the [ __ ] and that's how
we woke up I was dead
and the show takes a lot out of you just
doing like a little detail I'm sorry
what was I saying I was reading
questions doing the live show takes a
lot out of you physically well find out
tonight
um okay this is a question we got a lot
of times Jackie Vogelsang pit and peak
of the year I mean the big obvious but
but it's very honor what the pit is the
peak of the year I'm not gonna say my
agent cuz that's so obvious and I feel
like luan now every time okay what's her
rose my husband my peak of the year has
been the toast like the toast is more
than the breath ever was ever
we like yesterday hit 100,000 Instagram
followers this time last year on the
other show with all of the marketing and
everything behind it what we have they
know we had 75 at the end but we had
this time last year make the toast has
just been everything we've ever wanted
it to be and when people Amy people
they're like I loved the B and it's like
you can say it I'm proud of the breath
we worked hard on it
it was our concept no one ever isin gave
a shred of a [ __ ] about us they like
shoved us in some corner with an iPhone
like that was it's a part of the toast
couldn't be what it is without the
breath and I'm really proud of the
breath and whatever it's gone and for so
many reasons I'm so grateful that it is
gone because the chose to no firstly
every reason like yeah things everything
happens for a reason and it's like I
would say like last winter was one of
the lowest points ever and I mean we've
been through a lot in our life so like
it's no but that was bad that was that
was just bad really professionally but
if you would like told us all the
upsides we could we honestly we're
pretty like you know smart business
women but we were being so short sight
short sighted yeah you know and like now
that we are true like entrepreneurs like
the LLC is in our name like I'm so I
wake up every day and I'm like how do we
make the toast
TNN yeah like and I just love that so I
always was a firm believer and
everything happens for a reason and I
really did think that like even the
worst things that I've ever happened to
us like daddy passing away I'm like oh
this is the worst thing ever but I never
would have met Ben and then I never
would have had our future children so
like you wouldn't have to yeah and it
wouldn't feel so like really everything
does happen for a reason and in March Oh
Mike okay I know that everything happens
for a reason but like what the [ __ ] is
the reason like everyone the world
thinks I'm a terrible racist like and
hates me and like literally is sending
like
Judy on fire to my house like how like
how in the world is this happening for a
reason look what the [ __ ] and now I so
like a reason better than you learned a
lesson right right and and by which I
did Butler it was a very public lesson
and I could have learned it in a much
more private and less damaging way right
but now I see there a month later I'm
like oh like truly everything happens
for a reason
right like if anything good ever
happened to our old show like we're
still just making a salary like Noddy
it's not even from like a financial
perspective it's like a career
standpoint like yes we are and you're
always at someone else's will and for a
show that was really off the rails
sometimes like that just doesn't work we
were a liability right and so we can't
be the show that we want to be if we're
always answering to someone else and
it's like no one's to live like that
like feeling like you're in by your
supposable yeah and just send from just
like a human standpoint the toast is so
much good more than the breath ever
could for a million reasons and I feel
like it's because we're really in the
driver seat and we get to like make an
impact and like aside from the obvious
of like you know raising money for
organizations in highlighting good
causes like the toast brings people
together it's a good community there are
people whose real like social lives
professional lives like revolve around
the toast and the community that it's
built and that's it that has nothing to
do with us it's like a testament to the
people who watch it so I'm so proud and
I'm so grateful and I'm like I just love
the toasters I love the toasters and one
thing I was thinking about cuz people
always like commend us like you know
we're knocked down we got back up again
and like that takes off shrinks and like
you know blah blah blah but it's like we
only were able to get back up again
because there were people who were
waiting there was you guys who were
waiting for us the fact that you guys
like just supported us so much like the
second me announced the toast Mia 20
doesn't answer info right and like that
he does demanded that we start again
like if it was dead silence and like you
know we didn't like feel that way we
wouldn't have been as inspired or like
invigorated no to pick ourselves back up
so like it was a combination of yes
we're strong-willed people and like
we're gonna no matter how many times you
try and knock us down
we're like cockroach okay thank you
right a mess but also because like of
your guys's support we felt like it was
something that we could do ya know it
honestly like I never in my life six
months ago I thought I would say this
but 2018 [ __ ] rocked I mean like and
I can't believe it but like wow and
I'm just so I'm like literally before
all this happened I used to like when me
and Ben were in the car at like there
used to be like once a week I would look
around I'd be like my life is awesome
like I make so much money doing
absolutely nothing I have the most
amazing husband I love my family like I
live in this great apartment like I used
to like have those moments and I was
like wow thanks god you're the best like
that happen to me all the time and then
when March happened I was like I'm never
gonna feel that way again like I'm never
gonna
you know just snap my fingers and make
you know 15 grand from an Instagram post
and I was right that doesn't happen
anymore and they do have to work a lot
harder but now like I those moments
where I'm like wow my life is awesome
and I didn't think that was gonna happen
cuz when you're in such a dark place
you're like oh I'm never gonna get out
of it but like I'm back [ __ ] no and it
forces you to work harder because like
you used to be in a place where yes all
those great things are happening but you
used to say like if Instagram closed one
day yes that's your whole income and
yeah watching me now you're not you're
not in that know if Instagram close one
day yours you're a comedian you're on
tour right so you have a morning show I
you know any weekend yeah I've anywhere
well the life in the street I used to be
beholden to brands paying my rent uh-huh
and just hope that enough brands would
reach out that month and that I could
you know fill my not and they did and
it's the scene and also just on the
hopes that Instagram wouldn't one day
you know decide to delete my account or
go kaput
right no and then also at beholdin to
oath to pay yourself right so now I'm
like beholden to nobody I'm like an
independent woman I'm psyched Gloria
steinem's dream a small business owner
this is Laurie honestly large business
not gonna lie like this business is
large and it's only getting larger
here's what's to happen in 2019 more
merch more dirty jeans shows more toast
live shows more just expansions of the
brand I really think we need to do toast
beauty like host hello Harold bye Jackie
like like toast lipsticks I mean that's
coming any of you like work with because
makeup is not so much just distributor
its packaging you need some products and
all this then you have to be
cruelty-free right and it's all these
places shipping to each other so it's
like a lot of room for error so I don't
want to do it wrong um but I you know
what I'm gonna make a promise in 2019
it's gonna happen Jackie and you know
what we started the show with this and
this is a great way to end it you know
we are I'm an in did
woman baby oh right
we're not codependent women who are
going on TV to find a man we're
independent women who found men right in
the regular way I'm dating at okay what
else I think we're done what are your
resolution I'm not I'm not getting up
from okay in the next minute
what a resolutions my resolutions are
obviously to make a lot of money but to
also do good things with that money I
feel like you can make a lot of money
and then it just hits in your checking
account like no I want to invest that's
why we Robin Hood sponsoring the host is
the greatest thing because I make like
you know find money but I invested and
that's where the real moneys at an alley
Mohajir who's one of the toasters who
loves Robin Hood he's been giving me
like good tips you know stock tips
yeah just like investment like just like
investment like how to manage your money
diversify your portfolio
so basically Robin Hood is an app that
makes it really simple to invest money
there's no Commission there's no fees
and there's no cost so you can start
with as little as so other brokerage
companies charge you $10 for every trade
every fee all that stuff but the design
is so easy to use that you literally can
invest ten dollars and just watch it
grow I mean I'm gonna invest like you
know my Millions obviously and just
watch make sure that we are asking not
to teach you another lesson oh my god
totally what are we doing I have no
Millions I'm gonna invest like $50
because that's that's I think I can
handle that and then just watch it grow
and I feel like it's really fun and you
learn a lot like I don't know a lot
about I mean obviously doing the toast
has made me a more well-rounded
individual but I don't know a lot about
like investing and [ __ ] like that you
know so now I'm going to because Robin
Hood is giving all listeners a free
stock like Apple Ford or sprint to help
build your portfolio sign up a toast
Robin Hood dot-com that's toast
Robin Hood dot-com and that's really
exciting because what's better than free
nothin cuz this is the year of free [ __ ]
and most of what's better than making
money on your money oh actually nothing
I really want to snack after this what
should I eat snacky Oh what were you
talking about resolutions had something
to say to you but I camera oh if I told
you this time last year that in a year
from now you would have a new chin what
would you have said why didn't I do it
sooner like seriously I was cuz now I'm
in the my time
pop it's like I'm getting all my old
snapchats from last year and I'm like oh
my god and you know what's it's just so
funny because I've never been the type
of person to really like cared that much
about what I look like and I really like
even I see a terrible picture of me from
last year I'm like I'm like oh I'm
disgusting
but in that moment I was so happy and I
didn't care so like now I'm vain because
you know Sharon Kesey made me this way
but like and I really do wish I had done
this procedure before my wedding just
cuz I look back on pictures I'm like oh
but whatever like I was so happy and I
and I am so happy and I don't really
care about that stuff but like a part of
me is like damn [ __ ] why don't you stop
eating sooner nobody it's like a big
procedure and you have to like get to a
place you don't do those things lightly
so it really really has to bother
someone to go and get it physically
change oh sure yeah right so better late
than never
totally and I'm my whole life in that
I'm you know what and now like the
breath got your old chin the toast got
your new too and honestly I'm the best
of you there is nobody more deserving of
my new chin than the toast and when I
think of like the physical manifestation
of my old chin you know scratching his
belly belly but all walking around his
boxers that is the breath so remember
when we were trying to think of names
for the show oh my god be it's so many
bad options the Millennial morning show
good morning millennium good morning
honey house was so funny the morning
buzz I think we really liked if that was
taken we loved that and then we caught
that the toasters be like the buzzers of
the bees yeah it would have been really
keen our emoji could have been the bee
but it didn't work out and now we're the
toast which literally means everything
I'm hunting like we're so many things
we're alcohol
we're food were robbery were sister for
an action like mr. hood we're sir Arnie
and what a better way to end the season
finale I can't believe what a year it's
been the toasters are everything they're
the reason that the show is what it is
and I am so grateful for every single
one of you who just plugs in your
headphones and takes a listen since
bluetooth is now a thing or just syncs
up you know yeah with your air pods well
we'll keep active even though there
won't be a show keep up with the toast
on Instagram at the morning toast Jackie
O Jackie O problems girl with no job
clogged with no job pub with no job boy
with no job Olivia oh my gosh right body
by snitch
I'm so hungry hungry um all of them so
there's no shortage of content even
though the show is gonna be gone don't
worry we'll take care of you and we
still have three more patreon episodes
so if you really need some new content
we have some fun episodes coming up oh
yeah before the end of the year some
stuff about Olivia's wedding some stuff
about Olivia's wedding we're still gonna
do that episode with Ava about three
identical structures which was nominated
for an Oscar for Best Documentary Oh or
like one of those do you want to just
get into it really yeah no I mean I just
I loved it like I really didn't expect
to like it expect it to be bitter like
I'm not in this but I found it so
interesting and you know who I found the
most interesting thought whispering
Brittany Furlan really because I mean
like I knew like just as a binder I was
like oh she was everything and then like
a lot of people surpassed her and I
didn't realize that like that had
actually happened in real life to her
and I didn't know she got King bache on
Instagram I mean on vine that was so
interesting and I thought it was like
really cute the way that she ended and I
just like I like wonder you know what it
was that like really didn't catapult her
to the next level yeah and that like
felt sad for her but then she like fell
in love with Tommy Lee and like that was
really cute right and like he's really
legit and the same thing with the fat
Jew it's like the fat Jewish Instagram
page will always be like a staple of
meme culture and it'll always be popular
but like he himself is kind of like
taking a step back and I didn't know
that like he knew that like he was
overdue you know what I mean like he's
not over but he's like that he had
higher involved he's like retired and
he's like I'm the CEO of this huge one
company that's her that was acquired by
anheuser-busch I need like lives in LA
and just makes money and like does dumb
[ __ ] on the internet but isn't driven by
that thirst anymore which is epic right
and like the instagrams it seems itself
but that's not like what he's gonna like
working on full-time right he himself is
so funny and I've always said that and I
really think all the success he had is
just due to the fact that he is a funny
guy and he's nice like he's not a dick
but I really thought it was interesting
the way he spoke about that whole huge
drama and it is so what he said was so
true it was like before everyone blamed
to the fat geo for like stealing memes
like there was this conversation that
needed to be had about like means and
comedy writers and jokes and plagiarism
and credit because as much as nobody
wants to a minute it wasn't plagiarism
like it was just that is the way memes
work like a joke is made on Twitter and
then someone makes it into a graphic and
shares it on tumblr and then types it up
on reddit and
by the time that becomes a meme on
Instagram it's gone through 300
different versions and that there's
absolutely no way to really figure out
who initially wrote it unless they
contact you so I thought the way he
handled it was like this conversation
needed to be had and they put him they
made me the face of it and that sucks
but whatever and honestly I thought that
was like an epic way of dealing with
like a huge scandal and I was really
impressed by it
I'm really impressed by him everyone in
the documentary really even Paris Hilton
it's like dj khaled I could have done
with that but it wasn't a huge feat he
was one of the main you know and then
Kirill who I really like meet you he was
like making me sad he's making me sad
too he's talked about it on his
Instagram a little that he's not like
sad like that all the time just when
he's like doing things and travel right
and like could you imagine like not only
you travel so much but having to really
like black out every time you you travel
and then get up the next day and
tomorrow you're hungover and alcohol is
a depressant and like you're just like I
want it like this is no and I was
thinking I was like why does he keep
drinking just like like just [ __ ]
chill but then he was like I see the
most depraved [ __ ] I'm like there's no
way I can't be on their level and I'm
like ok Brad makes I just see like being
an [ __ ] and and like looking
judgemental
I had a culture of it like he's helped
to cultivate and what's so crazy is that
when he was talking about how he got
started like as someone he just used to
go clubbing in the city he was this
photographer and like he wanted to get
on his website he wasn't like titties
vaginas champagne
it was just like picture he used to take
pictures of pretty girls and put him on
his website and I got on it once I have
to find it it was just like a really
good sake he's like stamp and it like
everyone wants like a picture with
curled like to put on their Facebook or
like yeah any chose that you're out my
friend Rachel we're on it and we were
like so excited you should post a
picture I'm gonna find it we had seen it
on we saw him in the Hamptons at SL the
club and you took a picture of us we
were freaking out we were refreshing the
next day we were like when are we gonna
get it and it was my profile picture
it was my cover photo like it was
everything and like it's just so
interesting how he evolved into this
like whatever it is that he actually
does but back then he was like this
really like a Terry Richardson vibe
uh-huh like a club like a socialite
photographer and I also just like seeing
their houses like because you could
really tell how much money someone makes
based on like so Carell lives in New
York and a nice apartment and I knew the
building based on the background like
it's an expensive building like he does
well yeah you could just tell no he does
well um and his family was so cute and
it was just it was really sweet yeah his
parents were really cute I I knew you
would like it because it
he tells like the true story except that
guy from the toxic music video who was
just being a [ __ ] naysayer he said
something that really bothered me that I
was annoyed that they let into the
documentary because it's just so untrue
he was like you know a brand we'll just
contact that geo give him like 20 grand
and then tell him to post this photo at
this time and say this exact caption
which is and they call it organic
content that is the opposite and as
someone who did branded content for so
long and does branded content I know
exactly how the fat Jew does what he
does yes he gets a fee but he will not
post something that someone in a [ __ ]
agency made he'll make the video he'll
star in it he'll make the creative it's
like it's really a collaborative process
so so for this guy who's obviously
bitter and jealous being like yeah
they'll call it organic content but it's
just like an agency making a picture and
capturing like that's just not how it
happens yeah it really is organic and
that really pissed me off yeah but other
than that it was really well done you
know where likes and likes Haley Baldwin
well I thought that the celebrity I
loved when she told us how much of the
most she's ever made for the Instagram
post
Emel and the M rada and the Haley
Baldwin was just like they obviously
just added it to make it more like
emerado was interesting because her
trajectory has been really interesting
cook was interesting and I had no idea
that he started he got really famous on
MySpace and was being booked on MySpace
that's [ __ ] interesting it was it was
all really interesting it's really well
done you guys should watch it cuz like
we need more good and you have so much
free time now the BIOS has gone topical
documentaries like that before we wrap
we have a lot of thank-yous that we need
to issue okay first of all a thank you
to all of our sponsors who took a chance
on some unknown scenes this year and if
you are looking for one of the promo
codes like that you're doing your
holiday cards for mr. printer you want a
pair of em Jimmy shoots there's a master
post in the morning shows just with all
the codes and all the links to make sure
to hit that up it's called hash tag add
master post um yes thank you and thank
you for all the toasters for making us
so so that all of our sponsors and just
really perform entrusting us because we
really only work with companies that we
really truly love and and you guys see
that in us so thank you thank you to our
podcast platform audio boom audio booth
taking the chance on some unknown stands
once again and really just helping us
make this business what it is thank you
to boehner productions who hosts our
gorgeous set yes to Jake thanks to Jake
back here everyday who's here everywhere
he wants to be or not watching this
torturous show totally and Jason
here today but yes also instrumentals
here in our hearts right and a thank you
to the toasters once again you guys this
show that this wouldn't be here without
you we love you so much Thank You
Claudia for being a lovely ho Thank You
Jackie for just really being an anchor a
beacon of hope and that's where the time
structure for the toast because it was
just for me you know I'd never come
right yeah well you cuz you're a busy
woman
you're a by Teddy Mellencamp you hold me
accountable then maybe that's where the
term anchor comes from because I'm
anchoring yeah of course that's where
it's a little bit like anchor like a
news anchor oh you're such an anchor
I get it I was like dubbing Krait well
we love you guys have an amazing day an
amazing week Merry Christmas Happy
Holidays Happy Hanukkah all that stuff
Mary Kwanzaa love you and one more thank
you to our patreon members who pay our
rent yes who keep this show turning
thanks for keeping my heat on this
winter bye
you